the husband of nazanin zavari radcliffe
has started a hunger strike outside the
foreign office to demand urgent action
after his wife's most recent appeal was
rejected nazanin has been detained in
iran since 2016 after being accused of
plotting to overthrow the government
let's speak to richard radcliffe he
joins us live on sky news now richard
thank you so much for talking to us why
did you come to this decision this is
something you've been fighting since
2016
why now are you going on a hunger strike
outside the foreign office
that's right um we've been battling a
long time i've been on sky news many
many times
there were two reasons really
one as you said last week nazanin was
given a new conviction
lost her appeal all of a sudden um it's
very clear she's going to be put in
prison quite soon
we needed to act i had a conversation
with the british foreign secretary liz
truss to ask her what she was going to
do and she still said well you know
we're gonna talk to iranians and and
there will be consequences if nazney
goes back well that's too late so it
felt like we needed to do something
but but more broadly i've probably been
considering this for a while um i do
feel that the government strategy
is broken it's not going anywhere it
does feel like a policy of waiting um
and
you know we can't wait forever so there
aren't many things we can do we've been
trying behind closed doors to push the
government to do sanctions on iranian
officials who are holding doesn't need
to do
take around to court um and a variety of
things the government has been very
reluctant to do them so this is one
thing that we can do on our own so
that's that's why i'm here
you've been on hunger strike before um
how long did that last and what came of
that
that's that's right so i was on hunger
strike once before um in solidarity it
wasn't my decision autonomously i did it
when she did um and that was about 15
days that last time um in the summer so
so a different context um and it's i
mean what it probably got the iranians
very cross um but it got gabriella home
so it had a consequence a couple of
months later we'll see what happens on
this one this one um you know we've got
a couple of demands one of them is that
the prime minister acknowledges that
nazis are hostage uh that he starts
punishing the perpetrators that he keeps
his promise to settle the debt um and
that actually you know we're being used
a bargaining chip in the nuclear deal
negotiations that those negotiations
include an explicit promise or
commitment to end hostage taking um
we'll see how the government responds
and and we'll see in the days to come
how is nazalene doing she isn't in jail
issue she's out but she isn't free
that's right she she's at her parents
still um she's had the call to say you
know you're convicted but she hasn't yet
had the call to say come to prison um
and and hopefully that won't come just
yet
um how she doing she probably gone
through a range of motions shock
then anger
and then kind of a sadness that this has
come to this and how long and where we
are still
um and obviously now i'm in a bit of
worry as a wife as to what's going on
and where things will go it you know
hunger strikes certainly it's an extreme
act um and it's always a bit precarious
at the beginning so uh yeah it's a
stressful thing for us all
it must have been quite a difficult
decision to come to
yeah um you know it it's
um i mean we did one what two years ago
two and a half years ago i have to say i
thought that would be a unique
experience and that
you know when the prime minister came
into office he would uh resolve our case
and keep his word um
here we are two years on it
it's been something that
we have been racking our brains as to
what else we could do and probably the
trigger was last weekend
okay richard thank you so much for
talking to us